dowy reversing for his partner Mikey Anderson
they're both plus 15 but Ruda a shot blocked
barabanov a backhander while being tied up and
a save by rck he's worked on that this morning
at the skate a little bit more than normal now
Byfield is in he got checked and here comes San
Jose they might have numbers hurdle feeds it
off left wing side and a chance save is made
on Zena's bid from the base of the left Circle
did a good job to just stay at home watch it's
inside the dots there so it's a pretty good
angle and that's speet so the concern David
Ric making that stop on Zaden and then on shot
from the boards by hurdle 31 years of age out
of the Czech Republic David rck second start
since being recalled here's a turnover Off
to the Races zerland in shoots and scores Kings
turned it over and it costs them and the sharks
have tonight's first goal of the game so zerland
really makes the finish of the glove on it and
there it is right inside and unfortunately
Kevin fala if there's one thing with Kevin
you live and die and he thought he would have
a back pass but of course z was right there now
watch the Finish you see how quickly he decides
to pull the trigger that shot is way out above
the with under a minute to play in the period
here's a turnover gabov with Moore Moore with
a puck gabov to the net Moore to gabov broken
up by a stick loose Puck cleared away it was
behind the goenda chance standing up at their
own Blue Line gaver very after in the first
period And there's a couple of bounces couple
of sticks couple of skates everything right
there Hoffman plays it out farraro to thrun pass
in the high slot picked off here's
a break fala can even the score DS
scores Kevin fiala ties the game in
one you live and die with Kevin fiala puts
a little bit of a dagger an early one you
see the Sharks similar situation to Kevin's
turnover where it's in that gr area out near
the Blue Line watch the finish here by Kevin I
mean this is just pure skill stick out what Oh
my he probably made five stick handles and
then at the end watch this beat the goal
Pender King's tied up one to one well that goal
good for fiala on a couple of accounts now a
turnover a steal and a back Ender score Trevor
Lewis just like that bang bang two to one la
well that's what the sharks have done possession
down low no possession watch the quick backup oh
yeah the Miss of the sweep on the Poke check
twice by the goal tender you'll see it right
there miss and then he tries again right there
fala's goal is seventh Lewis's goal is fifth
now a chance and tight save is made off loose
Puck and off the arm feraro's bid from in tyght
hounded away stopped by David rck now in front
it comes hurdle a chance King scrambling now
hurdle rims it around Burrows dropped it out
up high but it comes out of the Zone well the
Kings normally really good in that home plate area
now again it's very tight there a lot of chances
that look dangerous are actually not that high
percentage at the same time sharks going right
to the front of the net Drew dowy turns it over
the other Way San Jose save is made off duclair
watch this fake with the the wave of the stick
by he did not bite at all download dubba feeds
it across shot lafier kicked out lafier
again ridden into the boards fighting off
the checking efforts of Hoffman got it to Kev
with a blast safe score on the rebound PL Dua
there's no better example than what happen
right here all three guys have decent size
and give du some credit here watch him go
down to one knee the spacing is really good
but watch this rebound one knee he gets
almost picks it out of midair the quick
hands works but Daryl that's all just Puck
possession for the veteran Mel granin he'll
send it into the Kings and loose Puck picked
up sharks with it to the net a chance save is
made for kempe kempe shoots missed the upper
right corner gabov for Kee let it go around
to grundstrom and to Roy his shot tip score
Adrien Kee right between the circles 4-1 outen
if you're smart you can do that and you
see Matt Roy's prepared to shoot it right
away and he's look at the head up that just
tells me he knows that kee's there he knows
he's going to keep it low tip goes low to high
that's a high slot situation ke's at the hash
mark Matt Roy wasn't trying to overpower it
he was putting it into an area where Kee was
turnover San Jose fiala shot tipped on Save
is made Stripped by hurdle now battles to get
it back from hurdle hurdle hands it off grin's
pass broken up in front pass two more kick it
Sav nice set up by Deno grundstrom hands it off
lazat out to Roy for gabov feet in the middle
grundstrom shoots scores no hit the post really
were moving well leaning away shot near post and
out in the middle to fiala shoots block Dy again
gloves it to his stick for fiala at the goal line
touch pass to Byfield from Kopitar save in
tight and the Sharks will get it down yeah
there was a black tape stick Nick that was in
the net and that I think that certainly caught
my attention that was not the puck it was a stick
again Toronto would review that they would take
a look at it anything that's close they take a
look at and they can contact the building here
the building here does not have to contact
them right yeah first uh look I thought it
was the stick to now front Kee robbed by ccken
and oh what a marvelous save I'm taking into
account the shooter the pass he reaches behind
himself this is close from going in to you see
the puck oh that he keeps it out and thrun will
lob it down into the king's end for the lefair a
chance I thought cab did a real good job along the
boards in his own Zone and then he just placed it
at the center now not looking for offense but
clearing the pressure nice move Kee in shoots
and scores oh what great moves entering the San
Jose End by number nine his second goal tonight 51
La so I know we talked about earlier
Daryl that neutral zone was real good
early by the Sharks and when a
player like Kee gets this much
speed it's one of those situations where
right there the defender comes across and
never gets a piece of Adrien and then he's
trying to hook shots in the third period 14
to5 La here's grundstrom with Lazard in the zone
grundstrom to the net shoots save rebound lazat
back cander save is made and a whistle for the
pad I think Blake thought he was going to have
the opportunity here you got to elevate a
little bit more but again leerer getting
chances almost shift after shift tonight dowy
for England his shot save rebound KF couldn't
get it on lafier does save made and that'll do
it Kings didn't want to let up that's for sure